[APPLAUSE]
STEVE LOHR: Stu, thanks for
that gracious introduction.
I kept looking over my
shoulder for the person who
was supposed to show up here.
And as Stu alluded
to, I've been writing
about the evolution
of these technologies
long before terms like
data science and big data
became common currency.
The fun bit of what
I do-- journalism--
is that it's a
curiosity license.
You get to go out and talk
to people, to learn things.
And this book project
gave me an opportunity
to go deeper than
I would otherwise
into what is obviously an
undeniably rich subject.
I signed up for it in 2012.
But really, it got
underway in earnest
when I took a seven month
leave from "The New York
Times" in the fall of 2013
through the spring of 2014.
And Columbia University
was kind enough
to give me a
[? bolt hold ?] to stay in.
And I was there and
traveled from there.
A decade ago when I did this,
you could just beg space.
Now you can't, so I was part
of the Brown Institute, which
is a collaboration of
the Columbia Graduate
School of Journalism and
Stanford Engineering School.
And they were kind enough
to give me a place to work.
What I'm going to do is read
the first two pages of the book.
Only two, I promise.
but I think it does give you
a flavor of what I was up to
and how I tried to go about it.
After that, I was going to make
a few observations about things
I think I learned through
the course of this research,
and offer my tentative answers
to some of the questions
that this technology raises.
The book begins with
two short vignettes.
One set in Memphis.
It was a large product
distribution center.
The second is in Atlanta.
And that is a large intensive
care unit at Emory University
Medical Research Center.
This will not be as
good as the audiobook,
but I'll give it a try.
(READING) Just outside
Memphis, an industrial symphony
of machines and humans
shuttles goods to and fro.
Their carefully orchestrated
movements and identifying marks
tracked by bar code scanners
and chips emitting radio waves.
Medical arms snatch the
plastic shrink wrapped bundles
off a conveyor belt as forklifts
ferry the packages onto trucks
for long distance travel.
Flesh and blood humans guide
and monitor the flow of goods
and drive the
forklifts and trucks.
McKesson, which
distributes about a third
of all the pharmaceutical
products in the United States,
runs this sprawling
showcase of efficiency.
Its buildings span
the equivalent
of more than eight
football fields,
forming the hub of McKesson's
national distribution network.
A feat of logistics
that sends goods
to 26,000 customer locations
from neighborhood pharmacies
to Walmart.
The main cargo is drugs.
Roughly 240 million pills a day.
The pharmaceutical business
is one of high volume
and razor thin margins.
So understandably,
efficiency has
been all but a religion
for McKesson for decades.
Yet in the last
few years, McKesson
has taken a striking
step further.
Cutting the inventory
flowing through its network
at any given time by
a billion dollars.
The payoff came from
insights gleaned
from harvesting all the product
location and transport data
from scanners and
sensors, and then mining
that data with clever
software to identify
potential time-saving and
cost-cutting opportunities.
The technology enhanced
view of the business
was a breakthrough that Don
Walker, a senior executive
at McKesson, calls "making
the invisible visible."
In Atlanta, I stand outside
one of the glassed in rooms
in the fifth floor intensive
care unit at the Emory
University Hospital.
Inside, the dense thicket
of electronic devices,
a veritable forest of medical
computing, crowds the room.
A respirator, kidney
machine, infusion machines
pumping antibiotics and
pain killing opiates,
and gadgets monitoring
heart rate, breathing,
blood pressure,
oxygen saturation,
and other vital signs.
Nearly every machine has
its own computer monitor,
each emitting an electronic
cacophony of beats and alerts.
I count a dozen screens.
Larger flat panels,
and smaller ones.
Smartphone sized.
A typical 20 bed
intensive care unit
generates an estimated
160,000 data points a second.
Amid all that data, informed
and distracted by it,
doctors and nurses make
decisions at a rapid clip.
About 100 decisions
a day per patient,
according to research at Emory.
So there's ample room for error.
The overwhelmed
people need help.
And Emory is one of a handful
of medical research centers
that is working to transform
critical care with data,
both in adult and neonatal
intensive care wards.
The data streams from
the medical devices
monitoring patients
are parsed by software
that has been trained
to spot early warning
signals that a patient's
condition is worsening.
Doctor Timothy Buchman heads
up one such effort at Emory.
A surgeon, a scientist, and
an experienced pilot, Buchman
uses a flight analogy
to explain his goal.
GPS location data on
planes is translated
to screen images that show
air traffic controllers when
a flight is going
astray-- "off trajectory,"
as he puts it-- well
before they crash.
Buchman wants the same sort
of early warning system
for patients, whose
pattern of vital signs
is off trajectory, before
they crash, in medical terms.
That's where big data
is taking us, he says.
The Age of Big Data
is coming of age,
moving well beyond internet
incubators in Silicon Valley,
such as Google and Facebook.
It began in the digital
only world of bits
and is rapidly marching into
the physical world of atoms.
Into the mainstream.
The McKesson distribution center
and the Emory intensive care
unit show the way.
Big data is saving
money and saving lives.
Indeed, the long view
of the technology
is that it will become a layer
of data-driven artificial
intelligence that resides
on top of both the digital
and the physical realms.
And today, we're seeing the
early steps toward that vision.
That's the end of the reading.
So that's what I did.
I ventured out into
this wider world
to get a feel of where
this technology shines
and where it stumbles.
And I built the
narrative in good part
around one young man
in one old company.
And Stu referred
to the old company.
The young man is Jeff
Hammerbacher, a data scientist.
Some of you may well know him.
He's 32 years old.
And I chose him because
the arc of his career
really illustrates the
spread in evolution
of these quantitative
techniques.
He was an Applied
Math major at Harvard.
He went to Wall Street as
a quant for about a year.
He started the data
team at Facebook.
Left there after about
three years with a tidy sum
and a reputation.
Became one of the fore
founders of Cloudera company
that many of you are
familiar with, I'm sure.
He's still Chief
Scientist there.
But these days he
spends most of his time
at Mount Sinai Medical
Center here in New York.
He thinks it's the
best use of his skills.
And I also chose him
partly for his life story.
We had an excerpt of it,
actually, two weeks ago Sunday
in the "Times."
But his father was a
General Motors auto worker
from Fort Wayne, Indiana.
Mom's a nurse.
Jeff is somebody
who's stepped well
beyond his background in life.
Beyond the data of his life.
And the old company is IBM,
whose data handling origins
go back to its founding
technology of the Hollerith
punch cards.
This was the cutting
edge technology
that was used to tabulate the
1890 census, when the U.S.
population had
surged to 63 million,
which was the big
data of its day.
And with IBM, I use that
mainly its research arm
as a conduit into some of these
projects that are in mainstream
use across the economy.
And both this McKesson and
Emory examples are part of that.
Initially, I was
going to avoid Google.
But it turned out, I couldn't.
Because I did a fair bit of
reporting on Nest for a chapter
on what we're now calling the
"internet of things''-- some
calls it the
"industrial internet".
I talked to Tony Fadell
at length Others there.
Yoky Matsuoka, who has
defected since I wrote this.
So Nest became a part of it
because Google acquired them
in 2014, before this book,
I had finished writing it.
In some ways it's not surprising
that Google is part of this.
I mean, given its
growth and evolution.
I mean, with search, ads,
language translation,
image recognition, learning
thermostats, self-driving cars.
The underlying technology
is much the same.
It's again, this layer
of data-driven artificial
intelligence.
And in that sense, personalized
search and targeted ads
have a lot in common with
personalized medicine
and precision agriculture.
So why is big data a big
deal in the wider world?
I think the main answer here
is it's a powerful measurement
revolution.
And we've seen this before with
other technologies that let
you see things as never before.
With the telescope,
you were able to see
biology and the
mysteries of human life
down to the cellular level.
With the telescope,
the analogy that you
can look up and into the stars
in the galaxies and see man's
place in the universe in
a way you couldn't before.
But I would argue that the data
science-- as more generalized
as computing as a
universal machine,
Turing-- is a more
generalized tool then some
that we've seen in the past.
And if the internet
transformed the economics
of communication-- which I think
it did-- I think data science
can transform the
economics of discovery.
And I'm certainly not the
only person that thinks that.
And it also opens the door to a
shift in the nature of decision
making.
And here, it's a
shift more toward,
decisions will be increasingly
based on data and analysis
as opposed to experience
and intuition.
More science, less gut
feel and rule of thumb.
But there's a real caveat here.
Because at best, what we
call experience and intuition
is actually a huge
amount of data
synthesized by a human brain.
But data that you can't
attach a crisp number to.
And it's sort of what
people talk about,
design thinking or
systems thinking.
There's an anecdote, an episode
that occurred at "The New York
Times" years back.
A gathering in the board room
that makes me think of this.
And it was early 2010.
Apple had introduced the iPad,
but it wasn't on sale yet.
And Steve Jobs was
around, showing it off
and answering questions.
And there were about 13
people in the boardroom
from various parts of the paper.
So some people knew
him, most didn't.
So after he does
his demonstration,
the editor asks him what
seemed a reasonable question.
It's a relatively
new product category
that they were
making a big bet on.
How much market
research went into it?
And those of us that
knew Jobs kind of
knew what the answer was, but
it was still fun to hear it.
His answer was, none.
It's not the consumer's
job to know what they want.
And Steve Jobs is
obviously not a model
for a generalization in a way.
But one of the things that
he always talked about
was what he called taste.
And taste to him was immersing
yourself and exposing yourself
to the best your culture has.
And again, a lot of
this was cultural stuff.
And his view was that doing
that would enhance your decision
making and improve your work,
whether you were a software
engineer or a fashion designer.
So it's not all
numbers by any means.
Now, data driven
decision making.
Haven't we been down
this path before?
Many times, but most
notably a century ago.
Frederick Winslow
Taylor was the father
of what was called
scientific management.
His time and motion studies
were going to revolutionize work
at the time.
And it's easy to look back at
it now, view it from today,
and you look at this as a
simple-minded deficiency
measurement run amok.
And he would be satirized
by Charlie Chaplin
in "Modern Times" with
machines grinding you up.
But in its day, it was seen
as a liberating movement.
And much of what's
being said about data
science these days has some
eerie-- the language is
a little bit more
Elizabethan-- but this kind of,
it can change everything
mentality was very much
a part of the dialogue then.
And it was a force that
was going to free workers
from the dictates of
authoritarian bosses.
And the economy from price
fix and corporate trust.
It was championed by leading
progressives of the day.
Louis Brandeis, known as the
people's lawyer who later
became a Supreme Court justice.
And Ida Tarbell, the
muckraking journalist
who took on Standard Oil.
Is it different this time?
Yes.
It's qualitatively different.
There's just so much.
There's obviously not much of
a comparison between the data
and artificial
intelligence tools today,
and Taylor's tools, which
were a stopwatch, a clipboard,
and his own brain.
But that said, of
course, it doesn't
mean that data technology
can't be abused.
Many of you know far better
than I, there's so much data
these days.
There's always patterns in it.
Are they significant?
And it's easy to make this the
fodder for bias fact finding
missions.
I know the facts,
now let's find them.
So what's worth worrying about?
Privacy?
A real concern.
But my view is that this
really should be manageable.
And in good part because we
have a healthy marketplace
of competing interests that
will get us not to a solution,
but to an accommodation
with this technology.
And we've seen that in the
past innumerable times.
At the turn of the century,
film cameras came on the market.
The brownie eventually cost $1,
a lot of money in those days,
but still affordable.
So people could take snapshots
and photograph people
in unguarded moments as opposed
to the old chemistry experiment
cameras where they had to be
frozen like a stone statue
to be photographed.
But this spontaneity
of photography
really scared people.
These people who took
snapshots, as they were called,
they were called camera fiends.
They were banned from beaches
and from the Washington
Monument for awhile.
In that case, people adapted,
social attitudes changed,
and things moved on.
Sometimes laws are needed.
In the 1960s,
mainframe computers
arrived and amassed
large databases
of personal information.
The IRS had tax returns.
Credit reporting bureaus had
a lot of personal information.
There was a lot of talk about
a corporate or government
big brother.
In 1964, the same year the IBM
360 mainframe was introduced,
Vance Packard--
who is better known
for writing "The Hidden
Persuaders" years
earlier on the evils
of advertising--
wrote a book in 1964
called "The Naked Society."
And it echoed much of
what we hear today,
including his warning
of what he called,
quote, "the hidden
eyes of business."
But what emerged
were basic rules.
First, the Fair Credit
Reporting Act in '64.
And later, the
basic Privacy Act.
You had baseline rules.
Some practices were
banned and changed.
There was a workable
accommodation.
And industries thrived,
including consumer finance.
And also, people make personal
adjustments in their behavior.
I mean, I do it now.
My personal concern is much
more my credit card transactions
being watched than
my browsing behavior.
It's what I'm actually
doing as opposed to what
I might be interested in.
So for me, the health
club membership
goes in the credit card, the
liquor bills I get with cash.
Ed Felton of Princeton, who
has a role in this book,
he's a former chief technologist
with the Federal Trade
Commission.
He's a computer security expert.
I first ran across him when
he testified in the Microsoft
trial years ago.
And he's a computer scientist
and public policy expert.
But Ed, when I was
talking to him,
said he likes "Breaking
Bad," the television series.
And he's interested in how
methamphetamine is made.
And so he looks it
up, but it's always
with a separate browser
in anonymous mode.
Whether any of this
does any good, I wonder.
Julia Angwin did a really nice
book on computer security.
She's now in ProPublica.
And kind of where
you come out is
there's no way to be
a privacy survivalist.
It just doesn't work.
But again, we've
been this way before.
With every significant
technology there's trade off.
Fire?
Cook your food with it
or burn down your hut.
Automobile?
People die in car accidents,
it pollutes the air.
But it's also a vehicle
of personal freedom,
gave rise to national
and regional markets.
And I think the
bet here is you're
going to see the same
pattern of adoption.
There'd be some rules, there'd
be checks and balances,
and social norms change.
This technology is just not
fundamentally different.
And it's a world that we're all
going to increasingly live in
in any case, so we might
as well get used to it.
But I'm a qualified
optimist on that front.
Again, in part, because the
market forces are there.
We have a lot of people who
are concerned and watching.
I think that will
sort itself out
as these things
have in the past.
I'm going to close with an issue
that I think is more subtle,
but it is concerning, I think.
And it's the black box nature
of data science in making
certain kinds of decisions.
Up until now, much
of the application
has been in things like
marketing, ad targeting,
product recommendations,
and the like.
A fairly prominent data
scientist, Claudia Perlich,
who used to work at
IBM research and is now
working for an ad
targeting firm,
takes the view that,
look, this market
is a great time to
experiment with data science.
She says, look, if
my algorithm's wrong,
what happens?
Somebody sees the wrong ad.
It's not a false positive
for breast cancer.
Certainly true.
But I do think we're moving
into realms now where
the stakes are getting higher.
Data science is being used
in medical diagnosis, crime
prevention, loan approvals.
Is statistical
correlation good enough
to make decisions that will have
a lasting effect on someone's
life?
And I think that's a
question we'll wrestle with.
Danny Hillis-- a
computer scientist
and artificial
intelligence expert--
says what this technology
needs is what he calls
"an explanatory assistant.
An audit trail that traces
the data and inferences that
went into the mix of a
software generated decision."
The technology,
Hillis says, must
be able to quote, "tell a story
about why it did what it did.
The key thing that
will make it work
and make it acceptable to
society is storytelling."
I agree.
And it's a good problem,
as they say in computing.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I was struck by
your first two examples, which
you've sort of lumped together.
But it seemed to me one
group could actually tell
whether what they were doing
with big data was effective,
which were the drug
people, who can measure.
And the medical
guys have more hope
until you have sort of actual,
peer reviewed outcome studies.
And medicine is
filled with people
who have gotten the wrong
conclusion from lots of data.
So how do you correct this.
STEVE LOHR: I'd make two points.
And one is, partly what
I wanted to do here--
and I was writing to
a moving target-- was
I was looking on the latter
side for research projects
that are sort of in progress.
That weren't going to be over
by the time this book came out.
And they have real
physical world
and commercial implications,
but aren't there yet.
And that one, the
Emory stuff, certainly
falls into that category.
The McKesson one is
interesting, in part,
because you actually
get a dollar number.
They did something.
And it's also a lot easier, to
be fair, because their data was
always pretty tame.
This was almost all
their internal systems.
Yeah, there's some weather
report stuff put into it,
but basically, this was
a cake you could bake.
I mean, people would argue
that that's not really
a big data problem.
But again, on these
sides of things,
I think that the most distorted
thing is the "big" in big data.
The numerator you can
inflate easily with video.
I mean, there's a lot
of water in the ocean
too, you can't drink it.
I think a lot of these problems
like the McKesson one--
which nobody here would
think that's big data--
but it's pretty interesting.
It applies the same
quantitative [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: That's the
one I believed in.
STEVE LOHR: Yeah.
Look, we'll see.
FDA Approval, everything that
this kid Hammerbacher is doing.
Mount Sinai is doing a
lot that's interesting.
It's Carl Icahn's money.
He also has a big
institute at Princeton
that's doing some of this.
All the genetic stuff.
I mean, nothing
has done anything
to cancer that is anywhere
close to quitting smoking.
This is always the critique.
Now, to say that it
isn't there yet-- there's
a lot of things that
aren't there yet.
You've got to bet on the future.
STU: Well, nothing has
done more for medicine
than cleaning up the water.
Doctors used to
be negative value,
now they're poking up
above zero historically.
STEVE LOHR: There's this
whole broader argument
about whether the
stuff is really
going to increase productivity
and benefit and such.
And Bob Gordon of Northwestern
is the skeptic that
makes just your point of view.
Nothing of this is close is
as close to modern sanitation
in toilets.
STU: And besides, fire
was a really good start.
Please, next?
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned that you
think a lot of the privacy
concerns can be addressed.
And I'm wondering if you
think laws are really
going to catch up with them?
If we need to be more active?
Especially as we have new
ways of gathering data.
One example would be,
many retail stores
now have free Wi-Fi
for the sole purpose
that they can
actually track where
people physically go since there
phone's automatically connect.
And then other
companies aggregate
that data and they say,
this person physically
walked into a JCrew or walked
into this other scenario.
And then they start
automatically sending things.
And they have it down
to your exact device ID
number, which can't be reset.
So they can trace
you everywhere.
Do we need more active laws?
STEVE LOHR: You know,
what you're going to get,
it's like this whole
debate about privacy.
The Obama privacy
proposals have come up.
The good thing is that
both sides are opposed.
The internet association, which
Google is, they don't like it.
And the privacy guys
are just up in arms.
Riddled with loopholes.
I think you do need some
baseline rules to set things
up.
But I also think-- from
a company standpoint--
I think some of this, like
the retail example that you
mentioned, I think
that's something
that companies are going to have
to decide what they're doing.
I think there are
a lot of things
that are going to be
legally just fine,
but are a problem they're
going to have to deal with.
And this is not to
your retail example,
I digress here, but remember
this Facebook thing?
About when they
got in the stream
and they could kind
of do something.
What struck me about
it was three things.
How modest was the intervention
if you looked at the numbers?
How slight was the outcome?
And how great was the rage?
And I think there's a
signal there to everybody.
Don't worry about it.
And getting back to Nest.
This is the human control side.
I realize this isn't entirely
responsive to your laws
question.
They first started with Nest
well before Google bought it.
And they did the
preliminary testing.
And they thought, well,
we have these sensors.
There's a near one,
there's a far one.
And we'll see how
people operate,
and then the machine
will take over.
And people hated that.
But they gave people logins
so you could constantly
check if you want.
Little alerts,
messages coming back.
Do you still want this?
They didn't change anything.
The machine took over.
But they had the
illusion of control.
Or to be fair,
they had the option
if they really wanted to.
And I think that's
the kind of thing
that is going to be crucial.
The answer on technology and
law is, well, of course not.
That doesn't mean you're
not going to get them.
STU: Good to hear the
Betty Crocker plus break
an egg into it moment repeated.
For those of you who don't
know, when the first cake mixes
came out, all you did
was add water and bake.
And they were quite
unpopular with the housewives
of the time.
Yes, I know what I just
said sexlessly it's true.
And they fixed it with
some market studies.
And the problem was, they felt
they weren't adding enough.
So they removed the
powder egg, made
you break an egg
into the mixture,
and suddenly the sales took off.
And no, it didn't
taste any better.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was very interested
in a point you
made about how human intuition
is nothing but connecting
a large amount of data points.
But then you also
gave an example
of Steve Jobs who, with a
very little amount of data,
knew that the iPad
would succeed.
So I wanted to ask you, do you
think that those large amounts
of data-- do you think the human
brain can connect them in ways
a machine can't?
What are your thoughts on that?
STEVE LOHR: And in
fairness to Jobs on this,
he's a great
product team leader.
This is a guy who's seen a lot.
There's a lot that
kind of went into it.
As well as his own prejudices.
The reason I hesitate
is-- people in this room
know it better than I--
maybe we just aren't there.
There's a lot of people, the
Ray Kurzweil's of the world,
it's a done deal.
We're just kind of waiting a
few years for this to happen.
A few years back, of
a colleague of mine,
John Markoff and
I at the "Times"
did a science series, actually,
on artificial intelligence
called "Smarter Than You
Think" is the rubric we used.
It was probably too
early, actually.
The nice thing is that
John broke the Google car
story because of that.
But in talking to
almost everybody who
was a real expert on this, none
of them are religious people,
but they had a real
awe for what we call
generalized human intelligence.
And the history of A.I.
Has been kind of humbling.
If you go back, people thought
this would all be a lot easier.
And yet, the
counterargument, of course,
is that machines are going
to do it differently,
but they can do it.
One of the great pioneers
of voice recognition,
Fred Jelinek said
to me at the time,
used one of his classic
lines, that airplanes
don't flap their wings.
Yeah, they'll do it
differently, but they can do it.
What do I know?
I mean, history would
suggest this has been harder.
Those kinds of things.
And frankly, the
management issue
with all of this is-- I didn't
mention here-- is awesome.
This stuff has been
good for discovery.
And will be and continue to be.
Knowing more should help
you make the big decisions
more accurately.
But it's not clear
that it's really going
to help with the big stuff.
I mean, look at
technology companies.
What's the message?
You get the big stuff
right, everything
takes care of itself.
That's a platform sermon.
Nobody cares about margin.
I remember having this
conversation with Gates once.
He said, when it gets
down to a few margins,
I'm out of this business.
He's gone now.
For the people who
are creating this,
the decision lesson is that you
make that big bet, you get it.
In theory, look at
venture capital.
Shouldn't a good
prediction market
be able to do better
than these guys?
Tell that to any
venture capitalist.
Because what do they plug in?
Who's your team?
What's your idea?
Basic business plan.
But we're not there yet.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that
being a privacy survivalist
today is near impossible.
And you didn't seem too
concerned about that.
So I'm wondering, do you
think anonymity or the ability
to be anonymous is
something that is really
valued in our society today?
Or is it something just on
the fringes, and should it be?
Is it just the
privacy advocates,
or is this something that
people should care more about?
And what do you think the
impact of the loss of anonymity
will be in the years to come?
STEVE LOHR: A few
questions there.
The evidence would
suggest that people don't
care that much in aggregate.
The issue, though,
one of asymmetry.
On one side of
that screen, you've
got grandma looking for
rheumatics and remedies
and gifts for her grandchild.
On the other side
of that screen,
you've got a PhD quant
from Google or someplace
trying to maximize
his lifetime value.
And that's just
fundamentally unfair.
The two sides are going into
it with different agendas
and a different
amount of knowledge.
And I think that's concerning.
But I think most people are
going to see value in this.
I was just up at MIT, did a
story-- it hasn't run yet--
about a young man who
essentially diagnosed himself
with brain cancer.
He studied his data, he's
not a liar, obviously.
But the broader point is
all this sharing of data,
of medical data.
And people at the Harvard
Genome Project and stuff,
people who really are
champions of this.
And he's one of those people
who has a stake in it.
He's 26 years old.
But he sees the benefit.
And he says, look, people of
my generation live on data
and we're going to want this.
And we're responding
to that in a [? lot. ?]
There's a thing called
Open Notes, which
allows now five million people
to see what their doctors are
writing about them.
So the nature of
medical information
is really easy to
put back together.
Moreso than a lot of things.
Particularly when you
get in the genome stuff.
You can take name, Social
Security, none of that stuff
is going to get--
so potentially,
I think it's a big problem.
I was a victim of identity
theft last time I did this.
This was 10 years ago.
And you find out
there's a system.
And first they charge
the $4,500 Cartier watch
to the "Times" credit card
which I'd forgotten I had.
And then you cancel
everything else,
but then eight weeks later you
get 10 store credit card bills
with charges to your account.
And then six months later,
Morgan Phillip's office
calls you.
And because this would have
been before 9/11, at that time
I'm not sure about
the driver's license,
but the medical card had
my Social Security number.
You're baked if
anybody wants you.
And changing bank accounts
doesn't really help.
But it was a system of crimes.
There's a guy who dropped it.
Then the people
dropped it off and made
the false identification.
And then there's the guy
who was the harvester, who
would be the equivalent
of a website now.
And what you realized
is this whole thing
about the bear and
the track shoes.
Two guys running and stuff.
And one guy's like, you
can't outrun the bear.
No, I don't have to outrun the
bear, I have to outrun you.
I feel that way about
myself, personally.
I mean, I'm nobody.
Why would anybody
be interested in me?
I guess it's just a long
winded answer, again,
to say real anonymity
is a tough thing.
And I'm not sure I want it.
Except for certain people, and
then it's a premium product.
There should be marketplace.
STU: --side of the
room, there is actually
a nice table back there
where books are being sold.
You may not be able
to see them by angle,
the pile is shrinking.
So you may decide
to go over there.
Please.
This was a paid
commercial announced.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I see that there's
a lot more data,
but I'm not sure that
there's an education system
to support that
understanding of data.
So I know that
data is expanding,
but looking at the
curriculum of my brother
who is in high school
and seeing the curriculum
of my previous
college, it doesn't
seem like there's
more people enrolled
in trying to understand
this sort of data.
So my observation
is that there's
sort of a danger in this gap
because sometimes in my role,
I'll present a data point.
And there's no questions about
where that data came from.
And if you talk about
a certain significance,
sometimes there's blank stares
depending on which audience.
So I can imagine if
you're telling a guy,
you have X percentage chance
of getting a certain disease,
and he doesn't know
what that means,
he could think he
could die tomorrow.
So I'm just wondering
if you think
my observation is accurate.
And two, within the
data community--
and even within government
and the education
community-- if this is
something that is recognized.
STEVE LOHR: Data
institutes, as they say,
are cropping up
all over the place.
And this is how
universities experiment
with new things without starting
a department, obviously.
So, Columbia's got one.
All sorts of places
are doing this.
A bunch of foundations are
lined up to push this one.
A lot of it has to do with,
it depends on what level
you're talking about.
General population
knowledge or experts.
McKenzie did this study
two or three years ago
about what we need from
a workforce standpoint.
And I think, off
the top my head,
it was 140,000 to 190,000
really literate data quants.
But would you really need is
the 1.5 million managers who
are savvy about
data to kind of let
it spread through the world.
I just look at what's happened
to journalism in my lifetime
in terms of, it
used to be economics
was something you couldn't do.
I was interested in it,
so I said all right.
But it was all anecdote.
And you know the old cliche,
once is a coincidence,
twice it's a trend.
That's changed dramatically.
And you can already digress,
because you can really
take a shot at it from a
statistical standpoint.
I mean, Upshot,
Nate Silver, Vox.
I think we should have
a manifesto that says,
this is stuff that boldly
goes between case study
journalism and real
statistical significance.
We run a lot more stuff
that, you now, this
is based on a longitudinal
study of 47 men in Denmark.
And we did self reported
studies of 147 people
who are unemployed and
how they spent their time.
It's really interesting, a huge
amount of interesting stuff.
Stu would probably know more
about this than I would.
But my sense is
that in universities
and-- I don't know about high
schools-- but more of this
is part of the language.
And the difference between
correlation and causation.
I mean, it's just more
of, "for example."
It's just something that
people think more about.
Stu, you probably know.
STU: Well, I'll just ask, how
many people here know people
in their families or friends
who complained bitterly
when last night it said there
was a 70% chance of rain
tomorrow, and it doesn't rain?
So obviously, they don't know
what they're talking about.
And you say, what do
you think 70% means?
And everybody in
this room grew up
with that custom of
data interpretation.
So, I'm curious what you think
about the educability given
these behavioral
economics studies
that suggest people don't
really understand probability.
AUDIENCE: I'm not so much
concerned about the pushers.
I know these institutions
exists and the curriculum
is there for people who are
very interested in data.
And you can be very good at it.
But that's still a very
niche part of the population.
It's the receivers
that I'm worried about.
Because privacy is
a concern, but also
misuse of this power of data.
So, you can tell
someone a number,
they don't know what
that number means,
and then you can really
manipulate people in that way.
And there's really no
protection against that.
STU: May I come into an old
classic book, just by the way,
before we go on.
It's entitled, "How to
Lie With Statistics."
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
STU: It's a wonderful book.
And I think about
it every time that I
see certain newspapers
do interesting graphs.
The other newspapers
don't even do graphs.
STEVE LOHR: None of us have
answered your question, really.
It sort of depends on
what you mean by people.
I mean, if you're really looking
at the population as a whole,
popular tastes
and stuff, I think
you're talking about people
who influence things.
Who can shape things.
I see that in
education generally.
The analogy I use in the book is
Dartmouth in the '60s teaching
basic.
The whole idea was this was
C.P. Snow's two cultures.
People who understood the
technology and the people
ruled by it.
And therefore, the whole
idea that John Kemeny and Tom
Kurtz for the rationale for
starting up basic at Dartmouth
was that potentially future
leaders-- flattering themselves
or not-- should be
exposed to this, by God.
Brian Kernighan of C++.
STU: Over there, I think.
You'll see Brian over there.
STEVE LOHR: Oh really?
He's going to make the little
environments program up
in Princeton.
He usually teaches
this course that
shows these basics of computing
to undergraduates who are not
computer science majors.
And I just I think we can
get more of it over time.
It's almost inescapable.
The regulatory issue
is sort of another one.
I think we're seeing all
kinds popular science.
Journalism's part of
it, as are other things.
More of this is taking hold.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
STU: Last one please.
AUDIENCE: So I think over the
last, maybe the 20th century,
you had graphs that could
graph the way that subcultures
tend to develop.
They start out as a
very niche market,
and then a group of people
surrounds around it.
And eventually, the
successful ones become hip,
and they become in
mainstream culture.
And then eventually,
they become monetized.
I think today that graph
is collapsing a lot
and that cycle is
happening a lot faster.
I was wondering if
you thought that had
any dangers for
homogenizing our culture
and making people more likely
to not branch out and explore
smaller subcultures, and
maybe limiting their ability
to be successful.
STEVE LOHR: Sure potentially.
I believe in free will.
Nobody's telling you you
can have the machine on.
A lot of this is being an adult
with individual responsibility.
An FTC commissioner said to
me, never quote me on this,
you can't protect people
from every dumb thing
they're going to do.
And the shaping power-- whether
it's media or technology--
I hear you.
And it's absolutely
true, in a sense,
but the way we deal with
this as individuals,
I think that's part of what
being an informed adults
is about.
Maybe I'm wrong.
STU: It's a good point.
Thank you very much, Steve.
It's always a pleasure reading
you, and even more a pleasure
seeing you.
[APPLAUSE]